you will not build wealth if you don't
learn new skills be excellent at what
you do solve a problem that's the shrewd
side then we need the Holy Spirit side
and I think when we have both I think
that that's how we can be the most
effective as Christian content creators
if you are a Christian content creator
today's episode is going to be extremely
powerful for you because we're going to
be discussing controversial topics
censorship and just how to express your
beliefs in your videos like hey which is
better the Canon R50 or the Sony zv 10
you know before we get there have you
met Jesus that's like a Jesus Juke you
know what I mean like you're just like
what are we talking about like respect
you know the viewer what are they there
for if you are a Christian content
creator today's episode is going to be
extremely powerful for you because we're
going to be discussing um controversial
topics censorship and just how to
express your beliefs in your videos and
so we have a lot of uh powerful tips for
you that we're going to get right into
with Sean Kel yeah super fired up up and
you know I'm excited about this episode
because of course our podcast is a
business podcast for YouTube in general
we cover tips for real estate agents
content creators business owners
entrepreneurs but I have a real passion
for Christian content creators that um
whether like overtly from a Bible study
Channel or whether like maybe they're
just kind of Christians thems and they
want to weave their faith into their
content and anywhere on that Spectrum
there's some unique challenges that come
up that I think we have some U valuable
advice for absolutely and we um these
are real questions that we get from our
community on a regular basis as well and
case studies that we've gotten from
talking to many different people in our
space so the very first question I want
to start with is how should people
approach um the idea of weaving their
faith into their videos yeah it's a
great question and I feel like there's
four ways to do it and so I'll go
through these number one I actually
think you could keep it private so I
sometimes feel like you might feel tooo
much pressure to share your faith when
that might not even be necessary or it
might not be your vision and and you
shouldn't feel guilt about it here's
what I mean on think media I don't do
Christian camera reviews and one of my
biggest pet peeves would be trying to do
Christian camera reviews it's what are
we even talking about like a camera
can't doesn't have a faith life like a
camera is is not spiritual in the sense
I really do believe All Things Are
Spiritual I think that there's too much
division of sacred and secular quote
unquote but no doubt about it every
Christian needs to be following the
Great Commission if they believe the
Bible and so they should share their
faith but you don't have to force your
faith into your business or your content
and again if you were doing JavaScript
coding videos like just be brief be
bright be fun to be done and and do that
and then realize that you know our
opportunity to share our faith maybe
we're like I need to share my faith on
YouTube but but you're just not even
doing it in your everyday life friends
family being a good neighbor so I think
I want to empower people that they don't
have to feel the pressure to feel their
faith and then just you know Francis
Schaefer said at all times share the
gospel and if necessary use words I
think there is something just about
being Salt and Light your kindness your
joy now I know that theologians and
ministers would say but of course the
gospel needs to be preached I agree but
what's the context what's the what's the
uh you know the vibe in the room and
unfortunately may maybe you maybe your
way of sharing it is in your bio on your
about page maybe you include a Bible
verse on your about page or something
and and that's it it's kind of like a
subtle like I know it Inn out for a
while they had Bible verses on on their
you know they weren't like preaching to
you while you were checking out with
your animal style fries but I subtly was
like I identify with this brand because
that Bible verse is such a simple thing
and that means so much to people yeah so
I think you could be subtle not overt
not you know and and weave some things
in but hopefully more than anything and
I think what we need globally but
especially in America is I think
Christianity kind of needs a Rebrand um
I think that sometimes we can be known
so much for what we're for uh I mean so
much for what we're against more than
what we're for like we just are more
about picketing as opposed to really
shining a bright light in terms of how
we love how we have kindness how we
treat others um just our style you know
over the years have gotten some feedback
we gotten a lot louder about
Christianity lately but some people were
like I always kind of thought that maybe
uh Sean was a Christian sometimes my
friend Mike signorelli was sometimes I
was like man he was talking YouTube and
I felt like there was like an anointing
that was the way his way of saying it
and so it I think you could just be
talking YouTube talking business doing
your art that's one option and and and
that's for between you and God pray
about it okay so the second level um I
think the second level is to incorporate
your faith like a Dave Ramsey or a John
Maxwell two Heroes of mine and so what I
love about Dave Ramsey and John Maxwell
Dave Ramsey is is he a minister no he
teaches personal finance is John Maxwell
a minister no he teaches leadership now
actually all Christians are supposed to
be ministers but they have a particular
skill a particular Niche a particular
thing they got known for and I think
that this is kind of the ultimate media
opportunity in my opinion there's a
proverb that says if you see someone
skilled at what they do they'll serve
before Kings not common people and it
talks about that if you develop a skill
an actual excellence and actual um
results in an area that number one is
where subscribers come from that number
two is where Revenue comes from the key
ingredient of success in business is
actual results and Excellence it's not
Theory it's not your spiritual feelings
it's not how much you prayed it's can
you deliver a result and solve a problem
and Dave is getting massive people out
of debt he's helping people in entree
leadership John Maxwell known as one of
the greatest leadership teachers maybe
bestselling leadership author so they
had to develop skill in their craft but
both of these individuals are really
known for weaving their faith in subtly
into their books overtly through maybe
sharing Bible verses universally sharing
those to just add value to people of all
different backgrounds but also then at
times even giving go presentations John
Maxwell is especially known for this
whether eventually at like a seminar a
conference he does maybe in a book maybe
in a chapter at the end of the book so
that's the incorporate and that would
mean be great be get really good at the
thing you do and then weave it in and
saying those examples maybe some of our
listeners would know they could see how
much of Heroes those guys are I believe
like John Maxwell does the Bible is the
greatest success book of all time and
therefore he has referenced one guy one
day a guy came up to him after he had
taught on leadership all day The
Listener was blown away like this is
crazy it's a whole different approach I
see how powerful this would be how good
of a culture this would be build how
much more this would lead to revenue and
impact and he came up to John after a
session he was like John I'm curious
like where did you get all this stuff
it's diff it's different it's a
different there's like love in it and
it's like a servant Leadership Model it
feels different than maybe the greed and
the pressure
or the domination or the putting others
down in control and manipulation and I'm
your boss and you serve me the way
you're teach is totally different John
where did you get all this stuff and he
goes if I tell you I don't think you're
going to like the answer you still want
to know the guy said John of course I
want to know and he goes I got all of it
from the Bible and he goes man you're
right I didn't want to know cuz he's
like you know a lot of times people
don't want religion or whatever to come
into it but I think that you you have
seen that over the years and impact that
that can make so I that would be that's
my preference out of the four options
but let's go to number three so you
could keep a private number one or just
you know it's not the platform you have
to force it into you could choose to
incorporate it pray about it three you
could start a second Channel or a a
second show and so um a good example of
this is my friend Rory Vaden and so he's
a Christian he has what's called brand
builders we'll link to a couple epis
episod he's got some Banger episodes on
the think media podcast about choosing a
name for your Channel or your brand or
your book that one's pretty legendary
and brand builders's company helps
people build their personal Brands
monetize their personal Brands cool
stuff and I would say that similar may
maybe not even as much as a joh or a
Dave like he's solving a problem it's a
business that solves problems for a
profit but then also what he did was he
launched a new podcast that I think was
also not even ongoing I think it was
it's called like eternal life seven
questions every skeptic should know or
answer about Jesus and I think he did
like seven episodes and it was kind of
his way of his passion for his faith his
passion for the
historical fact of Jesus and the
resurrection these details and wanted to
put that out there and I'm on his email
list I got an email that I think was an
all list
send about hey if you're interested in
this and maybe we've built some kind of
a connection you could go check this out
but again the key there was that's not
his main podcast or his main YouTube
channel he started a second Channel or a
second show to take a small side quest
here what I would encourage listeners to
do though is that sometimes if you're a
Christian content creator and you're
like I want to you know really share my
faith and I want to do all things all
right now I think that we always warn
people the side quest is be careful
starting a second Channel or show too
soon it's hard enough to grow one show
it's hard enough to grow one channel and
if I think you study somebody like a a
Dave Ramsey what does he been doing this
thing for like 30 years the amount of
shows or channels or books or
environments or like if he has a
conference on marriage or faith or
leadership you might go like well he
does a lot of stuff well yeah there's a
thousand people working for him too and
he's been in it 30 years when he started
it's like boom one thing what is the one
thing I solve debt you know baby steps
cut up your credit cards so maybe now's
the time for you to go oh wow I'm
already doing the one thing and I'm not
I don't want to like Jesus Juke people
and like force my faith like hey's which
is better the Canon R50 or the Sony zv
E10 you know before we get there have
you met Jesus that's like a Jesus Juke
you know what I mean like you're just
like what are we talking about like
respect you know the viewer what are
they there for what are they but if they
start a second show and you just let
people know hey by the way I know this
is a little bit offbrand for me maybe
it's a little bit different but I have a
separate uh show that you can can check
out and and Rory has done that and
others have done that as well you maybe
have your business Channel maybe you
start going personal Vlog personal
Channel but just be careful about when
you do it because it's hard enough to
grow one business hard enough to grow
one channel you could then grow the
second Channel and then you if you have
any followup questions on these let me
just hit number four number four would
then be to go all in with Christian
content and what I mean is that it's
obvious it's Christian content so in
this case there's many listening to this
right now that know they want to do a
Bible study Channel or what is Faith and
motherhood look like maybe it's
apologetics how do we defend the faith
or how do how can we trust the um the
Bible itself why is it reliable what are
different sources for that information
theology um or or different things like
that we right up front even maybe it's
business but it's like clearly it's like
faith in business and so you just kind
of go really overt listen I think all
four of these are great I think it's
about and you might also shift through
these in your career if you will but you
could keep it private and I think that
one probably gets too much stigma it's
not even that you keep it private it's
just that you don't force it on
something that's it's not practically
involved you can incorporate it you can
start a second channel to do it or you
could just go all in and then that's
also great people know exactly what
they're getting and you're kind of at
that point maybe also deciding this
channel is maybe to serve Christians and
grow on their faith
versus um maybe Reach people who don't
know God or have are exploring
Christianity for the first time so
trying to figure out kind of where you
fit in I think what you said about um
just living out your whether it's your
YouTube channel or your business as a
whole under biblical principles is so
powerful because like you said we did
that for years at think media without
very much overt you know Christianity in
your content at all and it was really
that we were demonstrating those the
positive side like you said it wasn't
about you know picking getting it wasn't
about telling people what they shouldn't
be doing or about protesting things it
was about showing the positive things
that come out of that biblical mindset
and so I think we've seen it in our
business you you mentioned I just wanted
to share too that we when when we get to
go deeper with people we actually got to
um share even more of those stories and
so when you're create first creating
your content it's you know picking one
of those four options but then you are
going to be going deeper with people
through courses or you're going deeper
through people with like we do
challenges or just different like web
classes different formats and those are
often an opportunity as well to even
weave in more of your story but also
just to like hit those biblical
foundations more to love on people more
to give be generous like having those
foundations in your business is going to
be one of the best um ways to to share
in a lot of a lot of times so well
there's also a couple things that come
to mind you know Seth Groen wrote a book
called permission marketing and and this
is an important marketing principle to
understand in general it's also the idea
of it getting someone to opt into an
email list they have given you
permission to follow up with them about
that thing as opposed to pushy marketing
and I'm not saying there's not a place
in time for Street PE preaching not a
place in time for just invasion of like
you know people got to hear I got to
preach hard but I I think that what
we're kind of also talking about here is
maybe that sequence of permission yeah
that maybe at some point someone they
want to watch that second show because
you've built more of a relationship with
them first and they're curious and
they've seen hopefully the fruit of your
Christianity in your own life and mental
health and marriage and character as
you've been being transformed and I also
would say all that like for some people
they might Al they might also feel
pressure I don't want to start my
YouTube channel unless I like actually
have my entire act together I think
that's also a wrong mindset because the
power of the go gospel is not your moral
performance the power of the Gospel is
Jesus's performance being perfect dying
on the cross for our sins and us no
matter where we are on our journey
always falling radically short of God's
grace Paul towards the end of his life
writes I'm the chief of all Sinners
probably when he was the most holy and
most Sanctified he had the highest the
greatest awareness of actually how far
away like it's almost like the closer
you get to God the further away you
realize you are because you realize how
perfect and holy and magnificent he is
if we start getting an ego like our own
moral performance I'm finally ready to
be the perfect example and now I can put
that on social media I think we're in
trouble because we are putting faith in
our own works as opposed to completely
and wholly on Christ and I think that
there's also some verses for this that
kind of came to mind where Paul like
writes to the Ephesians like be wise and
how you live amongst the world um in in
in Thessalonian iians it says like um
you know those who shouldn't work uh
need to get to work and you should live
peaceful lives amongst the world so that
they can see just your like like work
with your hands and be at peace like so
sometimes we can get so riled up and
listen I want to support those that are
also maybe on the front lines of the
culture wars absolutely conservative
channel news channels political channels
fighting for Christian judeo values okay
if you know what you're doing if you've
you chose you've choosen your enemies
and you feel the thing you're called to
but yeah 99% of us as Christians could I
think really benefit from getting you
know thinking about our own house
thinking about our kind of our own faith
uh and thinking about that example that
we're sharing and what I also kind of
like about this is I heard um this was
kind of back in like the Willow Creek
days I know they've gone through some
some different drama but that was sort
of the the Seeker friendly movement but
what what they learned was they there's
the Spectrum negative s and positive
seven when it comes to people's Journey
with God so a negative seven is is like
as far away from God as most of us would
would realize like not zero interest in
God maybe atheist agnostic and maybe
just living however and you still zero
is I have come to the foot of the cross
it has become clear to me like when
Jesus asked Peter and the disciples who
do you say that I am you know some say
he's a teacher some say he's a prophet
and Peter's like you're the Christ
you're the son of the Living God you're
you're you are the Savior and he goes
that it wasn't revealed to you by man
that is a that is a light ball moment
that has been revealed to you that is
true and on this rock not on you Peter
and your bloodline on this rock this
Revelation this light bul moment I will
build my church that that Jesus is God
but so that's zero and then plus seven
it's zero but and this is what's so cool
is because any of us can come to Jesus
no matter what's going on no matter it's
not perfect performance moral
performance your life might be messy and
it might get Messier after you come to
like the gospel is so powerful his grace
is so amazing that's zero seven though
is that process of being transformed
positive seven to okay I'm in Christian
Community I maybe starting to read the
Bible I'm starting to take my faith
seriously I'm seeing my life
progressively
transformed and I think that sometimes
Christians take the whole weight of the
world of like sharing their faith on
their singular shoulders and they just
think oh man like if I don't Jesus juk
people and like force this into my
content if I don't tell them like which
we should absolutely have urgency the
Bible would teach that in terms of
sharing our faith and how life is
fragile and it's short and you never
know like if you were to die tonight do
you know you're right with God now is
the time to get right with God
absolutely but also we all have a
different peace in the story and Paul
wrote some plant some water but it's God
who makes it grow so sometimes I think
that if we also see that we need all
four of these types of channels that
Christian content creators that have an
desire to expand God's kingdom be
thinking about where they fit in in
maybe just being a positive encounter
with a Christian versus being a
preacher and there was other stats done
that said it actually takes like seven
positive encounters with just Christians
not preaching encounters just positive
encounters like oh wow I didn't know
like oh that's your faith man I love the
way you guys are raising your kids or
like man the way you run your business
and your culture it's like so different
oh man you built that on the Bible well
that's that's then one seed now the
reverse what about negative encounters
with Christians and I know we all make
mistakes I've made the most but like
negative encounters with Christians of
feeling super judged when often times
sometimes we might have the bigger log
in our own eye feeling like super
criticized or just feeling like was it
the right context what's Wild to me is
that even in the book of uh Corinthians
Paul writes that we shouldn't judge the
world the World by their behaviors and
their actions is actually already under
judgment like that's the thing but it's
not our job to judge the world it
actually says we should be a little bit
harder on ourselves and inside of the
church because we have had that light
bulb moment and we should be held
accountable So to that point yeah I
think that if we can have and being
people that are feeling like where are
we on that Journey we need everybody
some good Channel that just oh wow
that's cool and and what are we after
we're also after the fact that like this
thing either works or it doesn't like
this should this and it does work
meaning there's been there was a study I
heard it referenced from Mark Driscoll
secular study that they studied that um
out of all the different worldviews the
way you could set up the household the
way that that you could live your life
that homes that had a mother and father
in the home that were praying and
attending church and were Bible reading
homes had the best results as a family
out of any other way to live not perfect
results not but for sure drama and
issues and we're always going to see a
Brokenness on this side of heaven but
this thing should actually work and so
us just sharing our faith praying being
thoughtful about what God is calling us
to do if you feel called like Jonah to
go preach Revival or you maybe can't
even escape the call you tried you got
you know and then you were brought back
in a whale's mouth spit out like I guess
I can't get away from this you you
really got to be faithful with your call
but yeah I agree with that I think that
um uh us living it out right is such a
powerful witness whether we're shouting
it from the rooftops or we're also
living it out with our lives so
considering all four of those different
content strategies how do you think
Christian content creators can be more
effective yeah that's a great question
and you know when I think about that um
I wrote down a verse um Matthew 10:16
says this Jesus talking look I'm sending
you out as sheep of Among Wolves so be
as shrewd as snakes and as harmless as
doves I think that this is one of the
most important verses for Content
creators Christian business owners um
and Christians in general maybe
stereotypically are probably really
known for being harmless as doves but a
lot of times not known for being shrewd
as snakes or shrewd as serpents and I
think that those are the two areas that
we should be growing in if we want to be
effective as Christian content creators
and here's what I mean shrew as snakes
is where we kind of we drop the ball
this is what's wild about him saying
that is there was a snake in the garden
a snake would be known by listeners as
even being kind of like the devil was a
serpent but by no means would Jesus be
saying like we should imitate or act
like but what is what are some details
of a serpent subtle crafty sneaky shrewd
intelligent wise trying to find ways to
give your witness in a way that does not
bring unnecessary persecution and
there's another verse where Jesus was
even kind of I don't know observing
criticizing maybe he said you know
actually like when it comes to worldly
wealth and money like the people of the
world are better and more shrewd with
money than the children of the light it
wasn't a compliment sometimes Christians
we're so we have so many mixed up money
mindsets so many business mindsets
mindsets about marketing this is why I
think this is so important oh you know
do I Market my brand I want to stay
humble oh what if money's coming in you
know money is the root of all evil no
it's not the love of money is but we're
messed up in our mindsets about money
our mindsets about marketing our
mindsets about all this different stuff
when when you see a verse like this it's
like no he's saying be shrewd get smart
I think about uh you know Moses was
trained in Egypt foundationally in his
life first and eventually became a great
leader the other part that happened to
him though was fiery uh Bush you know
encounter with God then he became a
great deliverer but he still had a
foundation of if you will practical
World wisdom not b not not in a bad way
but the Practical um wisdom and
intelligence Daniel Meshach Shadrach and
abedo had the same thing they were in
Babylon trained for three years and so
there's something about I think that
sometimes Christians struggle with
learning from secular voices I think
that we we're making a mistake if we
don't learn from people that are are
just good at business and sometimes you
know like we'll have different people we
had somebody speak at our conference
people would know that was you know
we're pretty familyfriendly brand He was
cursing the whole time and so you know
we didn't really hear any complaints and
we knew that that was his style and we
we didn't tell him not to because it was
kind of like listen we're a business
company this wasn't a church service um
and that's why that's I not the way I
talk the reason we brought this person
in was not because of any of these other
areas it was because that they have
intelligence and practical wisdom that
we need as content creators so I think
that we need to have a Grace like Daniel
did in Babylon to learn best practices
business principles marketing principles
all of that stuff if we're going to
thrive and succeed as um Christian
content creators content creators in
general but you bring in the other piece
and this is why this verse from Jesus is
so powerful because you you also need
the harmless and the better translation
is innocence of the D
which is being pure being unmixed being
free from Evil maybe you go to a
marketing seminar you learn a lot of
good principles but one of the things
someone's sharing is like that's that's
not integrous then you got to be able to
throw that out I've heard it said you
got to be able to eat the meat and throw
out the bones your ultimate filter is
I'm going to filter everything I learn
here through the Bible I'm never going
to let some tactic or strategy supersede
character and the principles of the word
of God I need to be able to distinguish
be between the two pure unmixed free
from Evil and without evil intent we
walk we are in we talk about marketing
all the time you're our CMO you're a
chief marketing officer you're amazing
at that but what we're trying to
cultivate at think media and I'm sure
we've made mistakes that's why a lot of
these things are not like a black and
white problem to be solved they're a
tension to be managed Jesus is like this
is the guard rails for this hey you
probably need to be a little bit more
shrewd more wise get actually like
better at your craft and like apply best
practices why are you over
spiritualizing everything learn from
Babylon for 3 years and then on the
other side though sometimes we could
just get so we can get in the mindset
the heart set the intent could be
manipulation could be you know kind of
be control could be being a little bit
dishonest in our marketing that's not
going to be innocent and harmless like
doves and so uh that also means risk
your lives as vulnerable non-combative
sheep like courageous Witnesses so
that's almost bends your brain cuz
you're like like how do I be both well
that's that's what we're being invited
to be I think as Christian content
creators we think about our ethics we
think about clickbait thumbnails titles
marketing you know we often say content
is King but marketing is Queen and she
runs the household it is your
responsibility as a Christian content
creator to get really great at titles
and thumbnails and I would argue to bait
the click if you want to catch fish you
put the right bait on the hook but
clickbait could go two ways it could be
unethical dis dishonest and deceiving
but it also could just be effective like
wow that's like wow that that really
made me click and then the video
actually delivered on the promise and
man some of maybe even our old Christian
Comm we could get so judgy because I
think also sometimes maybe if someone's
entire brand you're like man they just
when I really look they maybe claim they
say you know I'm a kingdom entrepreneur
I'm a kingdom content creator but like
visibly verifiably over time they're
operating in like kind of shady business
practices and manipulation and stuff I
mean if if over time that's the thing
then there's maybe an issue to be
addressed or you know you want to be
careful but sometimes you make like one
mistake like there's maybe been some
times and by the way that's why I read
the comments they'll say like man I felt
like that was a little click baity like
a little too much so yeah maybe we went
too far great let's be listening let's
have Humble Hearts we're going to need
that our entire Journey with Jesus we're
going to be able to need to have course
correction so I think that that's kind
of a cool framework and every body
listening probably goes to one or the
other extreme you're really good with
you want that that Purity was so
innocence Purity harm like and it's like
the Amish extreme respect to the Amish
I'm just like I don't want anything to
do with that but the the potential
problem with that is then we're never
actually in culture being effective and
making a difference the Bible did not
say leave the world it said you're in
the world but don't be of the world so
we're in the world what are we not of it
we're innocent we got the we got the
dove which also the Holy Spirit saying
we're different though we do it with the
different style and some stuff is so
neutral like money is neutral it is a
tool to be used greed to be avoided uh
money being a master the spirit of man
to be avoided but also not money to be
avoided because you need money for the
mission Jesus had women funding his
ministry female entrepreneurs were
funding the gospel it says and that was
the core source and also if you think
about it Jesus in another instance he
was able to they were like Jesus you got
to pay your taxes he was like all right
go fishing and so they went fishing got
a fish pulled out uh a drma or whatever
a coin from the fish's mouth paid his
taxes so clearly and throughout his life
he had the supernatural potential in any
given moment to just get money out of
nowhere to grow money on trees but 99%
of his ministry that was not how he
funded it he funded it through bought in
people whose lives have been transed
formed by his mission and his message
disciples following him and business
people women in particular following his
ministry that out of their wealth out of
their influence out of uh what they that
they were contributing that to the
kingdom that is a massive I think
invitation for us to be a lot more
intentional on the shrewd side you you
never you will not build wealth honestly
if you
don't skill up learn new skills be
excellent at what you do legitimately
solve a problem put in the work put in
the study put in the hustle do all that
stuff all of those conclusions could be
made that's the shrewd side then we need
the Holy Spirit side and I think when we
have both I think that that's how we
could be the most effective as Christian
content creators so you touched on this
a little bit but it's such a common
question I'd like to just go ahead on to
the question of um selling as a
Christian content creator now I know
this gets a little different if you're a
church or if you're someone doing
apologetics but like let's just speak to
the Christian content creator who maybe
is somebody who is doing content like us
that's doing um you know Tech content or
something that's not directly related
and they want to put their affiliate
links in or practice any of the you know
the best practices that we talk about we
have a a whole class at um what is it
build Kingdom expand expand Gods
kingdom.com that's right so expand godod
kingdom.com we have a whole class we
teach Christian content creators how to
actually monetize on YouTube and the
biggest question the biggest objection
we get is yeah but I don't want to I
don't want to do that that doesn't feel
right to me so can you speak a little
bit to that yeah and if I first say this
journey has been hard like this journey
prayerfully has been hard for me we're F
sometimes I felt like oh wow that's
getting a little bit yucky and other
times I've also felt like okay wow I
feel like I'm getting it right and so I
think the first thing is to set off on a
journey to say if you want to be in
business and let's be clear Goldman
Sachs said the Creator economy is going
to double in the next couple years half
a trillion dollar industry and that this
is and Yahoo finance said the Creator
economy is the fastest growing small
business type so I think the mindset to
have I think that church is not a
business and it should not be run like a
business but business principles should
be learned by pastors because a church
to be affect it essentially is a
business you have a p&l statement it's a
nonprofit entity the way they're most
set up so so I think one you got to get
into a mindset
that well if this is just a hobby that's
fine but if if you're a Christian
content creator that wants to do this
full-time and you want to fund your
ministry full-time you got to get a
business mindset and if you get a
business mindset there's no such thing
as business if you don't sell at some
point you have to sell now I know you
could say well maybe I just want to
create great content get views and let
YouTube pay me but know for a fact that
selling is still happening brands are
paying to advertise on your videos they
pay YouTube YouTube splits it with you
and you might want to think which as a
side quest some people say I don't want
just any brand to advertise on my video
you can go into your Google AdSense
account and say I don't want you know
adult content or alcohol content you can
filter that because you got to be
thinking if if you're not selling
somebody is it's the only way the
economy is going to work so I think you
have to change your relationship with
sales you have to make a decision that I
need to address my money beliefs and my
sales beliefs and I also need to develop
this skill because if you're going to
say successful Christian content creator
that's not broke that last over time you
got to remedy this issue my thought is a
couple mindsets that we I think are
helpful a shifting your mindset to
understand that to sell is to
serve we don't want to be this the car
salesman and the reason we don't want to
be them is we think about high pressure
we think about manipulation we think
about them pushing a car on us that we
maybe can't afford because they just
want to make a sale we think about them
pushing warranties and upsells that
maybe are just getting us and we just
the whole experience might feel pushy
and then we also think about tactics I
need to go scan your license and they
hold your relation hostage and they want
you to be hungry and there can get it
can get into some stuff where you're
like that's getting a little weird and
as long as we've been in this industry
there's been conversations we've had at
about events we've been at or like we
don't want to do it that way we saw
certain things we could take some things
away from it but there's certain things
we don't want to do but if you have a
product that really actually meets
someone's need whatever it is you're
selling and maybe that's you're
recommending a product you would never
want to we say affiliate marketing is
recommending products that you know like
or that you personally use and love that
you would recommend to your friends and
family you put a link in your
description and you make money in that
transaction this is an ethical process
business is not just a good idea it's a
god idea and the ethical process is this
product meets the need it blessed you
it's going to bless the person that
purchases it the person who created the
product the brand they are in business
their kids eat their family can eat um
and then Amazon if it's like the real
realator they make money in the process
and then you the content creator are
able to fund your content creation
because you have an income stream called
affiliate marketing and so done
ethically it's a win-win win winwin yes
and back to the you know maybe sometimes
you've learned you know there's
different things over the year but
you're always steering towards guard
your heart do it right be transparent if
you don't feel good about the the video
don't do it if you don't feel good about
the brand deal and it's not then don't
do it it's always better to have the
long-term brand but don't go to The
Other Extreme purposefully and
strategically and intentionally up your
videos to monetize but just in an
ethical way in a way that serves people
you know we can link in the show notes
to a book which will be our affiliate
link um that'll serve you and that'll be
amazing and it's actually called I think
business principles from the Bible
Daniel Rabbi lepin who I think is a a
Christian Jew uh so like Messianic Jew
that extrapolates just from the Old
Testament and the Torah really in
incredible opening mind opening
principles also just about how business
Done Right is how economies and
ecosystems and how money works so I
think you want to shift your mindset and
all of that stuff um and then I think
yeah just continuing to learn and
knowing that uh finally if you have a
product that helps people that rather
than like oh I don't I don't want to
kind of sell like I maybe have to do it
I'm going to do it reluctantly I think
you kind of really have to rewire your
mind to actually say no it's actually my
responsibility it is my ethical
responsibility to learn how to Market
and sell because I have a product that
can transform someone's life and
therefore the process of selling is
actually the process of clarifying If
the product is right for the person and
helping them clarify if it's right for
them answering objections explaining
what it is um and hope and we're trying
to do it at think media in such a way
that whether whenever we offer like our
course or something that it's just we've
uh built a relationship we're just
trying to explain what it is I often say
whether it's right for you or not I hope
you can enjoy our free content if you
have more questions we'll answer your
questions on it and understanding and
helping people come to a conclusion on
their own um if that that product is
right for them and in some cases that
it's actually it is untangling false
beliefs or helping that individual um
understand the pros and the cons this is
why we might compare so like if we sell
our course and for a certain amount of
money and we'll like compare it we'll
say well you're already spending money
you bought some shoes and you're going
out to eat and you're doing this and
you're doing that but none of that is
actually going to transform your life
this course course is going to help you
learn new skills so if you could compare
the value of this to the value of that
all those different frames just help
that individual come to a buying
decision and and oftentimes say you know
if you're serious about YouTube and you
know you want to commit to this and you
want to shorten your learning curve and
you want to save time then you should
join our program video raikit Academy
but listen if you're actually not
serious about YouTube you're still kind
of just on the fence then you shouldn't
join it like so I think there's like a
way to do it and um it's an absolutely
essential skill if you want to learn
don't hesitate from it be careful who
you learn from and that's one of the
things we hope we can help people that
you can maybe see the way we do it I'm
far from perfect but our goal is to
remain in a Biblical framework the first
of our seven core values is the Bible is
our blueprint so there and there sales
principles throughout the Bible and I'll
hit one more thing I know we've gone
long but at the end of the day too
actually everything is sales what do I
mean ministers sales makes it sound
weird but they're in the business of
persuading and explaining the gospel
Paul says that many times I'm a parent I
am in the business of persuading and
motivating my children to make good
decisions and to do things that are for
their benefit for their good to not harm
themselves to not die to especially the
toddler he's climbing up ladders he's
grabbing knives he's grabbing scissors
it is it is important like I want to
have a positive influence back to
harmless like dobes without evil intent
my intent is for the good of my kids the
pastor's intent is for the good of
humanity and his local church the
businessman's intent is for the good of
prospects ultimately wanting for and by
the way at the end of the day too sales
is incomplete if all you do is get a
sale but you don't deliver and you don't
have a good product which is a whole
another thing to build out but at the
end of the day too it's a combination of
all the above so
that's a CO that's a great topic and we
could hit that in Greater depth in the
future but um I hope some of that was
valuable so for those creators who are
speaking more directly about um you know
Christian topics or maybe biblical
topics one of their biggest concerns is
censorship and not being able to
actually be monetized or get their
content out there so what would you
speak to that yeah it's it's a great
topic there has been cases where people
have been Shadow bound maybe not for
Christianity maybe for conservative
values there's no doubt about it that
that Google um owning YouTube and maybe
social media in general kind of leans
liberal and so uh and there's no doubt
about it that judeo-christian values are
under attack period And so depending on
who is pulling the levers of these
different media platforms and whatnot um
it's a very relevant um issue so I wrote
down I think five tips for handling
controversial topics it's a legitimate
concern I don't think the conclusion is
ignore YouTube entirely because YouTube
you know you you can go to rumble but
there's also not even a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of the people
there so our belief and conviction Based
on data is that if you want to get your
mission out your message out there you
want to build your business you want to
build a Creator business YouTube is the
absolute undefeated best platform to do
so that doesn't mean it's without
problems and it doesn't mean if you pick
a particular content format that you
might get demonetized that you might get
a community guidelin strike that you
might get your channel deleted or you
might get cuz there are stories of that
I sometimes think that the stories of
that are maybe somewhat exaggerated
because you kind of get what you're
looking for I'm not saying they're false
they're they're true but you you hear a
story and you're like oh my gosh
censorship is so strong and and we need
to be fighting these battles and I'm
great for those on the front lines of
doing it but that but have you looked at
and also found examples of people who
are hitting really controversial topics
and not getting demonetized and not
getting their channels to deleted I
think what comes to mind is like Patrick
B David at Value tainment maybe nobody
doing it better than him and maybe one
reason is because he's willing to have
debate free speech at a table at a
podcast and and talk to people from both
sides and people of different beliefs
and he is a Christian and once also has
sat down and had religious debates and
has hit highly controversial issues uh
on gender and all this kind of stuff
that is happening in culture right now
so again for all those that maybe feel
like they're getting shadowbanned I just
would caution people that sometimes you
maybe aren't getting shadowbanned your
content just isn't that good you might
not be getting Shadow bound everyone's
views are down a little bit across like
and and we go so quickly maybe to a
conspiracy mindset and some of that I'm
not denying it I'm just saying maybe
truth and wisdom is a little bit in the
middle but here's five thoughts about
how to deal with it I think number one
is to actually read YouTube's policies
you can look them up Google them a lot
of people haven't done that and people
are like upset if they overtly break a
YouTube policy that is pre-stated I know
the objection is yeah but it's so vague
I mean are we talking about the US
Constitution our rights are under attack
free speech is under a tech okay but
YouTube also has policies so they're its
own they're their own platform so you
should read them number two is use
disclaimers I think that you could put a
disclaimer in your description or a
disclaimer in your video and the general
disclaimer you could look up for I mean
just go to chat GPT and type in can you
write for me a
disclaimer for talking about
controversial topics in my YouTube
videos and see what it spits out and use
something like that's not going to be
necessarily legal you could try but it's
going to help but here's the gist of it
this content is intended for educational
purposes
only because what one of the things that
is happening right is we're labeling
things hate speech okay um I don't agree
with with most of that right I think we
should have freedom of speech but if
it's educational content you might say
there's this belief and there's that
belief like for me um I am I'm a Bible
guy I'm a Bible is inspired guy and the
Bible is the blueprint for our company
so but the Bible is my worldview and
people would say that there's hate
speech in the Bible I disagree there's
the I can see it it's but I respect that
it's interpreted that way and I also am
happy to sit at the table not using not
saying that we both agree that the Bible
is going to be our measure so let's
debate let's talk here's the point this
is for educational purposes and and so
uh number one that could be your
disclaimer and it may be text on the
screen or it may be something you say
and it may be in your description so
number one understand YouTube's policies
number two use disclaimers number three
focus on education not provocation so
not only do the disclaimer but but
sometimes people are so mad that a video
triggered or maybe they're not mad at
triggered people but they're matter at
it's now demonetized when you're like
what are you obviously it was you're on
such an attack and I get that you're
passionate about your beliefs but you're
not really back to the shrewd thing um
wisdom intelligence find ways to give
your witness in a way that does not
bring unnecessary persecution some
people are out here like like just going
crazy like almost like trying to get
persecuted and then and then they're
acting surprised when it happens I think
that that's also the end of the day I
mean you should do what you're convicted
to but if you get kicked off of
somewhere if you get kicked out of a of
a college campus Because You're loudly
shouting and preaching I'm glad you did
that that's cool you did that it's also
their right to kick you out you're on
the front lines of that conflict but if
you're in provocation don't be surprised
when people are provoked you know and so
saying that I think there's something
about wisdom that education is greater
than confrontational and Sensational
content I get the power of a
controversial title or thumbnail I see
how that could work but back to and I
really see Patra bet David doing this
again he's he's hitting all of the hot
butt in issues but here's also how he's
doing it with research he's got a
research team now hours of research
presenting both views
presenting facts there's a lot of it's
like culture right now is like a game of
telephone where you whisper something in
one in the ear and they RIS Spirit to
the next person the news that we're
getting about Israel and Palestine the
news that we're getting
about uh pandemics the news that we're
getting it's all mixed and people read
headlines and things aren't verified and
I'm kind of like an a lean conservative
probably more independent but I'm an
equal opportunity person there's messed
up people on both sides people are
taking things to the extreme on both
sides and I think that we're out here
blasting our opinions and we haven't
done our due diligence we haven't done
our research and that might be one
reason why he's hitting controversial
topics affect ly and getting tons of
reach and not getting throttled and we
don't know what the future holds and not
getting demonetized I know some
conservative Outlets um like daily wire
has had like whole batches of videos
demonetized and just as one side quest
before we hit the new the other points I
also think like if that's our greatest
fear especially if you're coming from a
Christian standpoint I think that if if
you feel the conviction that God has
called you to preach where there is
Vision there will be provision and that
doesn't mean YouTube is your Source God
is your source so also who cares if a
video get gets demonetized I know if
your whole Channel and it could affect
your business and I'm I'm there with you
but there's other ways to monetize
there's people that are rallying support
through patreon because people are so on
Mission with you there's people that are
you you could have your own products and
service or merch or different things you
do like how about you take the
responsibility being like I can't
believe I have this free platform we
should know this free platform where I
am allowed to you know speak and
Proclaim and and and the videos are
spreading there was that recent shift
too where you YouTube changed and they
start they said they're going to stop
flagging I think the election
misinformation kind of stuff there's
opinions on both sides and they said
okay maybe we had a little bit of an
overreach they backed off of that
YouTube's not perfect but I think we
should think about this like YouTube is
free it's their platform and if you look
around at how many Christian voices
conservative voices whatever voices look
at how much reach they're all getting
it's pretty cool what's happening there
might be stuff happening in the middle
there but if you're Focus if you're if
you really are wise and having your Ed
education and so again if you can keep
getting the reach but you get
demonetized find a way to fund the
mission and trust that also God will
give you wisdom of how to do that okay
number four uh avoid hate speech and
misinformation kind of stacks avoid hate
speech please don't quiet down on real
truth like don't avoid saying if if if
people are offended by truth you should
speak keep you don't bend the truth
however it goes back to the style of
doing it and so um Pro keep proclaiming
uh uh truth and if someone just calls
something hate speech it doesn't mean
that it is but I think you can get my
gist avoiding it is smart and avoid
misinformation like and and ultimately I
think that reduces our credibility the
mainstream media has been caught for
this if you make a mistake correct it so
often too what will happen is
misinformation will happen and we never
even go back it's just constant all
kinds of smoking mirrors out here hold
your brand to Integrity do your due
diligence but then number five and this
might be one of the most important
diversifier platforms I think that
YouTube still would be should be in the
home base I think one of the great
examples if we're talking to Christian
content creators and looking at
conservative voices is uh JP seers so JP
seers probably everybody watching this
maybe at sometime has seen him um red
head long hair um hilarious really
comedian and stand-up comedian that
makes all kinds of different videos
about different topics they're very
witty they're very
wise and it's an interesting talk about
a way to get truth out but when you put
it in the rapper of Comedy which comedy
is one of the greatest Vehicles because
by by the way on both sides when people
get outrageously offended by the opening
joke of whatever comedian I think they
forgot the context of the room uh it is
a joke and it's it's it's meant to push
your buttons and it's the context of the
room is a free speech context it's
literally a comedian and so I would go
on both sides like while that it might
offend my values I'm not offended that
you chose to go to see a comedian and uh
Dave Chappelle I think is a great
example of this I think he's you know uh
Bob Bill Bill Burr great example you
familiar with Bill Burr I think he kind
of has the accent he kind of has the
whole thing this will be you know I'll
just go there one of his his jokes was
like people are all uh been out of shape
about when his life start and he was
talk about the abortion issue and he was
like man I think people are you know I
think you should have freedom to do this
and and people are getting so out of B
out of shape and conservatives are
getting B and he's going and people are
kind of like yeah yeah and he goes but
also we also have to just know that you
are killing a baby and and that's what
you're doing and it even now both
everyone's triggered like both sides are
triggered everyone's mad and he's just
you know speaking truth people are still
going to probably disagree with him but
he's literally the best comedians are
going to find those polarizing hard
issues find those things and get people
talking and get people so to that point
thinking about JPC he's using this
comedy as a rapper as a
vehicle and he is crushing it and
getting massive reach on YouTube but
he's also building his email list every
Christian content creator should be
building an email list that means that's
the only thing you're going to own a
text message list might be similar
Discord group or a Facebook group
although you're still Facebook you're on
somebody else's platform but when you
have someone's own contact information
should something happen with the
algorith even if you don't get cancelled
you just have a a direct connection you
know distribution to your subscribers
might be different at least you've got
emails he's also streaming on Rumble so
is Dave Ramsey they are streaming on
Rumble they're streaming on YouTube
they're streaming on multiplatform if
you actually think in a media World um
should you have the resources to do so
someone's like you know should I be on
Twitch also should I be on this new
platform and my My ultimate answer would
be like well if you can pull it off why
wouldn't you be everywhere we also
YouTube's home base you got to get your
YouTube game right but we post 60 Tik
toks a month 100 m yeah 60 across two
Tik Tok accounts WE Post 350 pieces of
cont Facebook reels were into Instagram
reels I actually want to get our Rumble
started it's more of a resources and
time and energy and thinking about it
like so diversify your platforms and I
think another example is rouson KD and
so rusan's a friend and some of the
things that they'll do in their videos
is they'll edit out words words that
will trigger the algorithm they also
will have certain content that is on
YouTube and then he's got his patreon
where there's full length conversations
daily wire has certain content that is
in their videos but then they've got
daily wire plus where conversations
could go deeper and and and by the way
so there's also many liberal YouTube
channels that are doing the same thing
so we can see this model out there I I
hope all these principles are clear and
helpful but at the end of the day um I
think you should be on YouTube and
understand the polit policies and use
disclaimers to focus on education and
not provocation and avoid hate speech
but of course stand for truth and don't
cave or bend have a backbone and and
follow the call especially the mission
and message God has called you to
certainly though avoid misinformation
and do your due diligence but diversify
your platforms and I think what all
these accounts are also saying look how
much reach they're getting on YouTube so
daily wire could say I don't think they
are but they could say oh man we YouTube
demonetized us or we're frustrated or
whatever but how many daily wire plus
users have purchased that membership
because of the free reach that YouTube
has given them yeah so the perspective
to have I try to stay neutral I I want
to fight for free speech and I want to
be in that and that's where I'm going to
lean but I'm also I just want to have
gratitude I'm like it's you YouTube's
choice to do this or that if one video
gets shut down that's frustrating five
others didn't keep going keep learning
keep pivoting um keep diversifying your
platform keep understanding YouTube put
parts of conversations that could be on
YouTube that maybe take it to another
level and then continue the conversation
somewhere else give people access to
things very controversial figure Alex
Jones and infow world wars has been
known to be cancelled everywhere kind of
across platforms and so he's set up
other websites and set up other things
and uh still has got people following
him we've mentioned you know maybe many
names which people have opinions about
but what has he done diversifies his
platform and you could be like mad
you're canceled now but what about the 5
10 years that YouTube gave you a bunch
of reach you know I think some people's
fear as we land the plane is like what
if I build my YouTube channel out but I
know that I want to be in politics I
want to be talking about the hardest
things in the Bible to talk about I want
to be doing this and what if someday my
channel gets deleted or shut down okay
legitimate fear and that would be deeply
frustrating uh hit tip number one back
up your content maybe post it other
places tip number two but yeah but what
if you just don't use it at all and
don't get the reach for the next two
three six 7 13 years before things get
so crazy that would be awful if it got
deleted but would you completely throw
the baby out with the B bath water and
forget that maybe it built your brand I
don't really actually know that much
about Infowars but like I mean how much
again free traffic and impact and reach
did they get before getting shut down
and and and and and how much money did
they make and how and how could they use
that money to reinvest and expand
there's no doubt about it that's why you
shouldn't ignore YouTube because there's
2.7 billion monthly active users the
algorithm it's it's amazing and so yes
of course you could be wise you never
know what's going to happen in the
future but why not crush it over the
next one to five years and and get some
market share and get some awareness for
your brand and do all of that we can't
live in fear and we want to be wise
and if you've Diversified your platform
even though that might be a sad day that
your thing stopped working there it
could be the very vehicle that got you
to the success that launched you to the
next level so those are a few thoughts
on controversial topics of course I
would encourage our audio listeners if
you haven't come over to uh come over to
YouTube for this one and if you're on
YouTube hit us with some follow-up
questions uh hit us with your thoughts
on this episode hit us with your
opinions and your thoughts on this
episode maybe tips and lessons you've
learned hit us with some stories or some
examples you've heard I mean you're free
to disagree with us it's open
conversation we're free speech Believers
ourselves and so um we've talked about a
lot but I hope some of that's helpful
yeah and if you want to continue the
conversation and go deeper on actual
YouTube strategy for Christian content
creators learn about monetizing your
content and gaining um that influence
and and expanding your brand then you
definitely want to head to expand God's
kingdom.com because that's where we have
a full master class on um exactly those
topic specifically for Christian content
creators so again that's just where we
can go deeper on all of this and spend a
little bit more time together if you hit
it when it's when we're going live with
that class then we get to do Q&A with
you and talk through your guys' channels
so it's a really cool opportunity so I
definitely recommend going to expand
Goods kingdom.com to dive deeper onto
these topics as well and make sure that
you're also subscribed to the podcast
and following these conversations again
cuz we definitely want to hear your
thoughts in the comments and so we will
um get to see you on the next one